همم روسيا نستقبل رامي القليوبي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي من موسكو اهلا بك سيدي
على فرانسفانتي 4 فلنتوقف عند لهجتي اميني
مجلس الامن القومي الروسي همم مؤخرا امسي
حول المواجهه الروسيه مع الناتو هذه
السرديه الجديده لتقديم هذه الحرب في
اوكرانيا لماذا التركيز على هذه السرديه
وتقديم الامور هكذا الان
من وجهه النظر الروسيه الغرب بصفه خاصه
للولايات المتحده تحارب ضد روسيا ولكن في
حرب هجينه بالوكاله وليس في اطار حرب
مباشره وهذه الحرب تجري عن طريق تزويد
اوكرانيا بالصواريخ واسلحه عاليه الدقه
وتحديدا صواريخ هايمارس
النظافه الجوي كما دخلت فرنسا على الخط
بعزم تزويد اوكرانيا دبابات خفيفه فارسيه
ترى ان نيته اصبح مورتا في هذه الحرب بشكل
غير مباشر
والمانيا والولايات المتحده اعلنت بانها
ستزود اوكرانيا لاول مره باليات قتاليه
هذا تحول في الاستراتيجيه الغربيه
لدعم اوكرانيا بهذا النوع من الاسلحه
روسيا تقول بانه لن يغير من موازينه القوى
هل الامر كذلك فعلا
هذه الاسلحه قد تغير موازين القوه تكتيكيا
في حاله تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه من
استرداد بعض الاراضي لكن هناك على المستوى
الاستراتيجي هناك حاله من شبه التكاثر
فمثلا اوكرانيا الان تسيطر على مقاطعه
كرسون في الضفه الغربيه لنهر النيفر ولكن
اذا انتقلت الى الضفه الشرقيه فستواجهه
صعوبات لوجستيه في نقل الى الكوبات
وستواجه نفس المشكلات التي قد واجهتها
روسيا في الضفه الغربيه ولذلك همم الان
الجاني الروسي والاوكراني غير قادرين على
حسب الصراع لصالح اي منهما انه ولذلك لابد
ان تنتهي هذه الحرب بالمفاوضات لانها ليست
حربا تنتهي بهزيمه كامله لاحد الطرفين
وبالتالي في هذا الصدد هناك صحف روسيه
تقول بان دخول المدرعات الخفيفه الغربيه
على خط المواجهه هي بدايه مواجهه مباشره
صح تعبير بين النيتو وروسيا هل فعلا الامر
كذلك ام ان هناك يعني حرص على عدم تجاوز
اا الخط اذا هذه التكافئ لكي لا تفسر
المساعدات على انها تدخل مباشر من النت في
في اوكرانيا ما هو السقف
تحدثنا عن التدخل المباشر فهو يعني مشاركه
افراد من حلف الناتو في عمل القتال وهذا
لا يحدث
اما اذا تحدثت عن طريق الصدر عن الصحف
الروسيه فهذه الصح هي ليست للانسان حلقه
الدوله ولكنها تعكس التوجه العام
لرؤيه القياده الروسيه ولكيفيه التصوير
الامور امام الراي العام الداخلي قبل
الخارجي